good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the National Press Club I'm
Sonia Hill grande I'm president of
National Press Club
didi Myers one of our panelists this
evening said unequivocally in the
Washington Post quoted today there is no
humor in Washington tonight we may or
may not prove her wrong that is for you
to judge and I want to tell you how
pleased we are to present this program
in collaboration with Comedy Central and
I'm going to turn it over to Tony Fox of
Comedy Central who's going to introduce
the rest of the show and thank you again
for coming Thank You Sonia I too would
like to welcome you here this evening on
behalf of Comedy Central we are very
excited about this panel I would like to
start by introducing our moderator a
veteran CBS newsman mr. Morley Safer and
co-editor of 60 minutes
okay
next to him is the former White House
press secretary for President Clinton
and current co-host of this MBC NBC
program equal time miss Dee Dee Myers
next to Dee Dee is a humorist and author
of the nonfiction bestseller Rush
Limbaugh is a big fat idiot in other
observations mr. Al Franken
next to Al is the press secretary for
Speaker of the House Newt Gingrich mr.
Tony Blankley next to Tony is the star
of the hit comedy central series
politically incorrect and anchor of our
indecision 96 presidential campaign
coverage mr. Bill Maher and lastly is
longtime GOP strategist and partner in
the international strategic consulting
firm of Davis manna fort stone Inc mr.
Roger stone thank you what Somerset mom
said of the literary life can certainly
be applied to politics this year he said
make people laugh and they think you're
a trivial fellow but bore them in the
right way and your reputation is assured
and I think we can properly describe mr.
Clinton and mister dole as properly
boring neither is certainly very funny
at least not on purpose
I'd like to ask the panel particularly
bill and Al it looks like a pretty dry
time ahead that's not have we not heard
every joke we can possibly hear about
Clinton and oh how I defer out of age
well okay first of all you got a lot to
work with Clinton dole let me just
review DOL's old he's extremely old why
is that why is that funny um what is
that although you do all kinds of jokes
you know how old do you sound he's 72
years old when he won California he
declared it for Spain
old and is old saying um so you got the
old you got the you got the temper so
that older of what well all's temper oh
I smell where have you the duty but an
editing room doing this tobacco and you
take that dead yeah but all doesn't have
a father anymore
he hasn't it's kind of kept it under
wraps he's all these two old habit I'm
that's good
I agree at a distemper shot and then
with Clinton you have your uh you know
you have the adultery thing which you
don't wouldn't no one in his right mind
would raise that in front of him yeah
space speaking of which I spit was being
white which Don Imus who some people do
find funny at yes does the Imus flat
prove once and for all that people in
this town have no sense of humor no I
think it proves that at the dinner that
night when they were serving the Italian
chicken that really they had cept a
little bit of British beef and the whole
town came down with a mad cow disease
because everybody's was wandering around
frothing and falling on their bottoms no
but I think the thing that struck that
makes me think there is no sense of
humor is that why on earth would you
invite Don Imus if you want gentility
but you know the bottom line is don't -
wasn't very funny
he was me he was funny I didn't think he
was very funny I thought it he was not
some of his stuff was funny but in
aggregate he he wasn't we were there we
were there I was there who else was
there I was here yeah the interesting
thing about it was and this is just an
observation of I don't want to get into
critiquing Imus because I'm not why did
he go critique you yeah I'm doing the
White House Correspondents Dinner in a
month
and and he stole a lose-lose situation -
are you going to be as lewd and and well
I don't have a lot of time to prepare so
I'm basically just going to do what he
did today what they wanted mark Russell
they wanted cheeky they didn't want
insulting they got Don Rickles on acid
you don't yeah why would anyone invite
Don Imus if they wanted mark Russell
what I was going to say about being
there first of all if you were there it
was a lot worse than seeing on TV
because um you know we're animals we're
all animals and people are giving off
like these chemicals I'm like oh my god
and but what was interesting about the
Washington audience was that people were
shocked but they would do this they
going oh my I can't believe he's doing
ha ha that's funny
oh what a horrible [ __ ] and it was just
like I don't know if was nervous
laughter or just they don't know how to
be an audience in this town no what do
you make of it well I did this dinner
last year and I also got into deep [ __ ]
because I said a bad word I guess right
about that yeah what I always find
interesting is that this country is such
a hard time holding two things that are
opposite but also true in their mind at
the same time for example OJ Simpson did
kill his wife and there was a racist cop
both things are true in the same way Don
Imus
I mean you this town does not have a
sense of humor and Don Imus was funny
you're wrong about Washington we twist
the town that wants to cut taxes and
spend more money on education at the
same time we understand that concept no
birth apparently Beatrice Harris of all
OJ Simpson was acquitted and this is the
United States of America so I am NOT
gonna sit here a man who was cleared by
our justice system especially while he's
at large right absolutely I don't think
this town has an absence of humor but I
think it has in excess of hypocrisy
because the humor people were laughing
at those laughing Imus every morning
driving to work and then when he is more
visible suddenly everybody is shocked to
find out that he was saying what they've
been laughing at for the last few years
but is there a line yes
forget whether and I didn't cross it
what pissed me off about this thing you
laughing I wish to Christ you would but
I'm telling you there is a line what
bothered me is I was interviewed by all
the papers after Don Imus thing as well
as after my own because they gave me
some crap for this but I would not in
front of the president make a joke about
his infidelity with his wife sitting
right there I wouldn't do that to any
couple at a dinner party and
and I and I didn't I mean that is where
I would draw the line and and so I hate
when they've called me up and locked me
in with that I think no there is a
distinction what would you hold on of it
so you say sex is the line or yep or
would you admit it would you have made a
joke about smoking marijuana for example
in front of the face I think I did but
it wasn't about him I said I said Marion
Barry had a plan to get drugs off the
street one gram at a time I you know I
think when you're caught in a hotel room
on videotape the gloves are off for that
subject but my experience what is the
mayor of this city and I will not sit
here
boy how you are liberal let me but let
me address the to the three hired guns
here do they are they uncomfortable
being the butt of jokes politicians or
do they really love it
no I think it makes most politicians a
little uncomfortable some of its
good-natured humor I mean Clinton takes
a lot of shots on everything from his
weight in his you know love of
McDonald's to things that are much more
touchy
um he wants the jokes about his weight
that makes him I mean play morally he
eats a lot but that absolutely Valle
nura but that's a great I mean whenever
they make a joke about his weight he's
going yes thank you that's good it makes
me vulnerable okay I'm a Randy kind of
redneck but blubber bubble guy may work
but let's make fun of the blubber and
not the well that's definitely but but
what may work and what politicians are
comfortable with are not necessarily the
same thing
and I suspect Tony's had some experience
with this as well I mean some things
that make you appear like a regular guy
still make a politician uncomfortable is
what is Gingrich not like he doesn't to
be joked about he doesn't he doesn't
like jokes about Bill Clinton's
infidelity he I know I know what use is
to discuss it for the rest I know I
don't know bear the van I will not
discuss something like joke about I
won't discuss Clinton's infidelity again
tonight now new doesn't like jokes about
his first wife that I know well I will
you you do know that all right yes I've
read that and I also when I did that
dinner for Clinton he was sitting next
to Gingrich and after this dinner I said
to gang Gingrich I'd like to have you on
my show anyone I don't think so
I'd like to ask you something uh cuz mom
you guys like God knows I'm still paying
no you uh army yeah
Graham they love love it when you chide
him on a family safe is likes to mr.
songs you got shoes I shouldn't say
defend you work for perhaps the softest
target this country's ever had in
politics
Dan Quayle right supported Dan Quayle
that's true how difficult was it for you
and for him well we had a lot of trouble
because no kidding
frankly he thought roe v-- wade were two
different ways to get across the river
it was really
what are you saying he's stupid I'm not
saying it sounds like what a stupid guy
would say I think he took it it frankly
pretty good natured be you'll notice
that he passed up this race for
president in 1996 so there's just so
much abuse that one human being can do
was tell me so I don't know dude he is
stupid yeah I was going to that but that
was the other thing they're good I think
I'm hold on I was gonna ask the man who
knows it was he the buffoon that these
guys made not not in the slightest
I mean he was a that's a spit-take is
what that's called it's very old no I
look this guy was a respected United
States Senator perhaps cast into the
spotlight by George Bush a little
earlier in his career than had been
expected but well liked and well
respected in this town and he was not
the he was not the caricature of him
that was created well you know that's
not the thing though is if if if Pat
Moynihan had been characterized as a
lightweight he you'd sell it won Meet
the Press
Dan Quayle a little problem and that's
is he's you know he's not a heavyweight
do you I mean let's just be doesn't just
be frank about it be a mission he's
doing it you know no I he was too easy a
target and that thing he said at the
United Negro College Fund where he tried
to get their slogan do you remember that
yes you could - what would you say it
word for workers that make me laugh
every time
I'm thinking back you know I'm talking
about like oh yeah it's a waste of
terrible a mind how true that is right
or something along those lines
Tommy funding has it been is it becoming
more difficult to parody politicians
because they've become parodies
themselves the way they they Pender for
love and pander for votes I mean the
very idea of the possibly the next
president of the United States flying
around in the Chiquita banana airplane
you couldn't come up with I mean well
that would be Bob Dole that's another
thing Bob Dole does he's he calls
himself Bob Dole something you can do
with Bob Dole been working on Bob Dole
ordering breakfast I hear that yes Bob
Dole would like the scrambled eggs don't
undercook the eggs Bob Dole Bob Dole
doesn't like his eggs all runny
so there you got something with Bob Dole
but never seriously have they they do
you people support them you three in
doing some of the most foolish things
anyone any of us have ever seen on
television like what like well for
example the the the New Hampshire
primary campaign I mean they were out
there doing just being silly
chopping wood they don't chop wood you
golden [ __ ] one dumb stuffed it that's
that's because if our candidates stand
in one place to read position papers you
guys don't cover them when they go out
to chop wood you'll be there with the
camera no doubt about it
what that's a very good point Dave
Lincoln Chuck what's it what's a good
point what he just said because you
won't cover it if because the media
doesn't cover of reading a position
paper but they cover a photo opportunity
and I have seen a politician get out of
a limo and milk a cow and amazing that
describes America better
you got good night so yes but if they
only did position papers we would
ultimately cover position papers their
pen they're they're trying no you'd
cover the one candidate who's out there
chopping wood and milky and getting out
of the limo and milking the cabbage
right got it I done it I think you are
boy as if it feels like some classic
age-old conflict yeah go at it you too
yeah I mean I think was Nixon who said
the only thing worse in politics and
being wrong is being boring if you bore
the voters with long white papers and
detailed positions on the issues you
guys won't come cover the candidate
record long but did you break a few laws
that's that's the nice thing about this
whole whitewater thing we can recycle
all those slogans I saw a jail to the
chief bumper sticker yesterday and and
it was no you've been to stay on Galena
as the as the keeper of the Nixon flame
indeed are you fairly chilly these does
uh well there's a certain sense of deja
vu but remember no person is above the
law riders got a not need oh hey there's
a prankster of all time
dick tuck just decided me does anyone
remember the dick tuck yes we did
haha or Donald Segretti these are
classic Democrat dirty tricks Roger
Donaldson grass a great head good Tommy
denisa was Watergate those you two were
probably too young
this Watergate did that open the
floodgates for a more edgy more brutal
kind of political humor in this country
I think Watergate Vietnam the Kennedy
assassination change how Americans feel
about their government morally I don't
know are you running for something mr.
Harkin know what I mean that's a good
boy Lee Allah jump in there actually mr.
I really do because you know comics what
we look for is to find that place in
politics or anywhere in life where
reality is it divergence with you know
what people are really thinking and you
know Nixon you knew he was lying
it was it was too great a target even
Comics who never looks at a political
thing in their life could not wait to
feed from the Watergate trough and you
know once you take the president every
time you take the presidency down in
dignity it stays at that level until the
next guy takes it lower
there was Watergate and that was you
know at some point later the president
telling an MTV reporter what kind of
underwear he wore well there is a line
between those two yes we say you take
the presidents down in dignity do the
president's not willingly happily step
down in dignity themself there Gerald
Ford they trip down but III agree what
he says I mean it is a it Clinton going
on TV talking about his underwear really
makes him a target he invites it he that
invites you telling he's a man who's cut
our deficit in half I mean this is not a
desperate stop uh Eric or please ah
Hania laughter laughter yeah yeah that
big sucking sound yeah yeah newt
gingrich we all know fairly fine
a brutal therapists that are atheists
and that our therapists tell us to live
with our depravity because that's all we
have is that true yeah I bet they were
rolling in the aisles oh no are there
any liberals
liberals here who've accepted your
depravity how many liberals here who are
traitors Democrats who are traitors
that's a funny thing oh they won't admit
it though yeah uh how about decay a lot
of decayed liberals here this is all
funny material the speakers let me I was
about to say he can dish it out he's
unintentionally can he take it
of course he I mean I think most the top
politicians can in fact take it I mean
they go to the events they can laugh at
it I mean you can't I don't think you
can make it through a career without
being able to take a tough line against
you but also and it's been doing it
newts done it I mean and for that matter
a lot of a lot of ver eisenhower took
the all the pummeling of his you know
jumbled syntax so I think sure top
politicians and always take it measure
of it morally when you I let me say
something in defense of Gingrich when
you are he is a thinker he really does
think about stuff Clinton to and when
you in this town
I think express your your mind the way
your mind has been ruminating about
stuff you're shot down you have to stick
to the very boring narrow things of life
you can't go off about giraffes and some
of those other things that he said which
we're actually interesting and the
future he said we could have remember
the thing about have using the [ __ ]
and the crippled in space because there
was no that was gonna be a lyric
no no that was Newt Gingrich Tim O'Leary
you know what I'm talking about he said
that in space there's no gravity so that
you know you were going on honeymoons in
space and honey you're going in
honeymoon in space for these a very bad
idea there's so much pressure you don't
want to add to being an orbit yeah I
mean you know wait you know gravity I
find is helpful
and the last thing you need
hany they give you some idea about their
welfare reform program if he's talking
about honeymoons in space so then you
are saying that that that Gingrich a
politician's
of at most levels can take it and yet
you say they can take it and yet there
is a line well beyond which you're not
supposed to be able to take it I mean
really is how to at any given moment
decide that you're not going to take it
I mean that was a problem Bill Clinton
had the speech the other night do you
actually get up and walk away chances
are if you got up and walked away he had
been condemned for having a thin skin
and and yet then people condemned him
for not getting up and walking away
because he doesn't have any pride in
self respect but there was one one
difference with the dinner on the radio
and television correspondence which was
the president wasn't the only one being
attacked and part of the outrage in the
media was that Peter Jennings was being
attacked and bernard shaw was being
attacked and all of the icons of the
media were being attacked right
alongside the president which I think
added to the level of discomfort it was
it became not just about the president
well I think you may not have been
attacking me that's what media really
got outraged right their own when it
moved from it's one thing to attack the
president but Peter Jennings that is way
beyond the pal but look you say there's
this line or this sense of decorum given
that that they go on MTV and talk about
their underwear haven't they and and
given that that wasn't a proper politics
has become a fairly dare I say tasteless
occupation they leave them something why
do they deserve hold on why do they
deserve a line you know anything goes
and they love to be folksy they love to
be one of us they love to be identified
with no they don't love it we love that
they do it they don't want to do it you
think Bob Dole wants to go and do this
stupid crap that he has to go run doing
you know what and every day is going you
know what I've served my country for 40
years I know how to run this
and how to run the Senate I've gotten
this past I've done this why should I
have to go out in Mill Creek I think
they feel uh he doesn't want to do what
we make them do I think they feed off
that now they don't not him
you actually wrote letters at all I
think politicians reflect the society
and the fact that the line has been
moved in society and then in reporters
except said certain statements and
politicians end up mirroring the society
that they represent sort of and it's
very hard to abstract yourself out of
out of the society and the standards of
what's acceptable or not whether you're
a politician or a journalist and plus
you see that and gentlemen I think they
reflect the society in this town I don't
think they flat reflect the society this
country do you really I think insert in
terms of changing more certainly they do
20 years ago no 21 year old would have
asked the president what he was wearing
under his trousers it wouldn't have
happened what I mean al do you you were
on Saturday Night Live in the 7 20 years
ago and I mean what was it he's an
American icon the show was really good
sorry but it is it has it changed in
terms of what's acceptable what you're
able to say what you're able to say 1978
on NBC and what you're able to do now
satire I don't know yes I yes it's
changed I can get lovely I'm to get to
Vietnam and Watergate right yes uh I
guess so I'm not with the show anymore
so I'm not sure what we do this year
what they can do this year but why we
have the v-chip exit that the simple
challenge is that only about 26 million
people watch three Network News's each
night and there were going to be a
hundred million voters and the challenge
for a politician is to reach beyond the
people who watch the news regularly to
the rest of our voting which is why you
go on MTV if you go on on Leno or
Letterman if only there was a show that
dealt with the news what was 22 I can't
think of one
and the 30 million people watch I think
30 million people don't watch butter I
think the politicians leave themselves
open for this much you get him a guest
shot on friend but the handlers the
handlers put them on these shows because
it's a handlers job to put them on shows
correct
it's a handlers job to reach audiences
that you might not otherwise reach which
was very intent we did that with great
intention 92 so I Bill Clinton went on
Arsenio Hall it's why he did MTV the
first time and it was very effective
during the campaign he reached out to
all kinds of audiences that he hadn't
previously been able to reach and he
paid a very high price for it when he
got to Washington well because the
Washington the established Washington
press corps didn't like these what they
saw it as the Clinton administration
trying to go around the Washington press
but I think that there as I think the
next this campaign and the campaign's in
the future we'll reevaluate that a
little bit for the exactly for the
reasons that you raise and people say oh
well Bill Clinton went on Don Imus in
1992 and Don Imus helped Bill Clinton
win the New York primary there's some
true to that and he helped the Don Imus
become a national not just in New York
celebrity hope this show become
syndicated and then the monster that he
created came back and did him this this
idea that the monster recreated Clinton
goes on our senior Hall and plays a
saxophone 1961 Richard Nixon went on
Jack Paar played the piano this is not
new it's just
the point whoever the candidate is very
specific questions about whatever the
controversy of the moment is and
sometimes the handlers the handlers
would like the president to talk about
the fact that he grew up in Russell
Kansas and his father went to work in
overalls every day for 40 years I mean
there's a opportunity to float their
ideas Clinton comes up I mean bill
hey things uh that reporters can say no
yes for example I don't want to support
what I just said you could Google tactic
here morally I am you can take the news
and go a giant step further is what I'm
saying I my goal is basically to change
the society through my humor and so far
I think I've done a pretty good job come
on bill help man you don't
why is rough limbaugh waiting in the
men's room he's very often in I don't
know there's a whole other element to
humor though which is humor is a very
humanizing particularly self-deprecating
humor and I think politicians try to be
self-deprecating and sometimes they are
effective at it Jack Kennedy and
sometimes they try and don't quite know
but that but self-deprecating is self
aggrandizing well but that's why it's so
effective I mean you know I mean for
those of you from Washington the
gridiron dinner on Saturday which is off
the record but Kristen Senator Chris
Dodd went in there and gave the most
self-deprecating hilarious speech all
the jokes were about himself which which
doesn't marked contrasted Don Imus just
being mean to everybody who was in the
room Chris Dodd was funny in my view
most of what Donna Anna said was not
funny Chris Dodd helped himself Don Imus
if he ever wants to come back to
Washington probably didn't do himself
any favors although probably helped
himself with his own audience but that's
a skill that not many people have to be
able to be self-deprecating you're right
it's the best weapon you have Kennedy
had it very few people do it takes some
real comic timing and knowledge and
instinct and what most candidates should
do if they're not funny and most of them
are not is not trying to be funny
because that's just painful but the
temptation is always the George Bush had
a joke remember that make my 24-hour
period I've never heard anybody screw up
a joke that
just don't try to do it and also when I
vote Republican when I'm for a
Republican it's because they're not
funny I don't want a funny Republican I
want a mean old man who's gonna watch my
money
and there's nothing funny about that
watch my money don't be funny that's my
Republican there you go Roger you're all
set for another year I could charge big
for that due to all politicians lie yes
no tape up do all politicians
oh oh there you go Clinton where are you
insane well is it so that's such a sad
comment on it's a mere question no but
that that that so many people would say
yes so quickly I do not think all
politicians I don't think all
journalists lie
oh no no journalist I know all copies
live we just learned out about comics
are the ones who don't lie that's why
they laugh it is laughter is an
involuntary response they laugh when
they hear the truth they've been
thinking in their head but nobody said
yet that's what comics we are truth
tellers it's true do they all are of
course you can't get elected let's just
say most of them lie Oh [ __ ] you can
you can always tell you lose toe in
their line cuz their lips are moving
more sweating above the lips yeah you
cannot get elected without lying Paul
Tsongas you know tried that he is always
a guy who tries that if he gets state
Senate what's that he was a politician
he was elected by accident did not get
elected because of the lake
probably
no he said I'm not Santa Claus and he's
not president oh it's okay that's that's
the lesson there
Tony do they all lie I think politics to
politicians lie as much as everybody
else does no no come on they a lot
little more than no no I mean I don't
actually I don't think so right you're
lying
ma'am I think that most people do not
make it through a lifetime without
telling a lie from Times yeah but that's
not the question of course that's true
so I think in politicians don't lie
anymore
so what then the average person does
when they're talking to their boss so to
their spouse or to their fitness is
different they're asking for our trust
so the question is do they lie more or
less than other people yeah I think
there's a tendency for most people from
time to time not to state the full truth
but to pick out politicians as a class
and say they do it more than other
people we're talking about this class
tonight and do their lie the answer the
consensus is a lie because the people
are too big babies to accept the truth
so they have to lie to get elected you
can't tell them what we really have to
do the truth is often transitional in
the politicians mind in other words I'm
not going to run for another term and
then maybe I'll change my mind later so
that's that's not a lie that's a genuine
changing of one's mind
it's the reason I ask the question is
you have this extraordinary gap between
the campaign and the fact what he says
in the campaign and what he says and
does once elected that to my mind much
of that involves lying yes correct
let me not always you're not able to
accomplish what you set out to I mean
you say politicians you're talking about
a pretty broad class of people we're not
just talking about Bill Clinton and Bob
Dole I mean there's a whole class of
people out there who I mean there is
some of these people are motivated by
public service and they go out and they
tell the truth and they try to do what
they were elected to do but they don't
always accomplish what they set out to
do for a lot of different reasons Bob
Dornan never lie
well exactly that's why he's a
translation exactly there's a guy who
never lies the guys who get one percent
in the poll of the ones who don't lie
the other ones now also he's crazy but
he's saying what he believed no no he's
always very very uh yeah but what they
want to do is they want to get the votes
of people who really disagree with each
other that's what you have to do so you
have to lie I mean Bob Dole is a
position on abortion you know for
example what is it you know I guess he's
against it and except in the cases of
rape incest and the survival of the
candidate and so it changes all the time
because he doesn't want to offend
whoever he's talking to ones but the
truth is that he has been consistent on
the abortionist you and he hasn't
misrepresented
oh god that's what I read can have
trouble hmm when he's asked about it but
he has to vote well that's a he doesn't
ask when things were 25 years he's the
mirrow thing and then after the debate
then there's another explanation but I
really meant I think well I think Dee
Dee's right what happens is that that I
think a lot of these politicians run for
office with good intentions but when
they get there they find it's not as
easy as it looked from the outside that
they can't really accomplish what they
wanted to because it is institutionally
not as simple as that if that's true and
I doubt it it suggests it suggests that
these poor creatures are the most naive
people these come do you think when
George Bush said read my lips no new
taxes that he knew at that moment that
as soon as he's elected president he
would raise all he liked the sound of it
right and the operatic know something he
believed it when he said he knew at the
time that it would help win the election
yes that's what he knew and he knew that
it was a macho way of saying Michael
Dukakis will raise taxes when he's
president and I won't and more to the
point I believe the opposite instance is
even more telling the opposite instance
is Walter Mondale telling the truth at
the 1984 convention and saying I'm gonna
raise your taxes and getting slaughtered
now there's the truth and look what a
getting slaughtered look at the
lincoln-douglas debates and
please and by the way they were not
funny funny but as as Lincoln move our
Bob Dole of
so I said earlier yeah he's old as
Lincoln with Maria is old as Lincoln was
moving further south in Illinois he
tailored his message regarding black
people and he got Sutton got more and
more southern in the language he was
using described it as he was moving
south now he was a pretty honorable guy
but he found it necessary to least
tailor and shape his message even so I
mean if you're saying do politicians
like old people in all time sometimes
have to shape things yes but I think
that the have but honesty yeah I mean
but the presumption is a journalist that
you look down on politicians today as a
class that you're superior to I think is
unsupported by my experience either with
politicians or journalists actually that
may have been what they taught you about
Lincoln and Australia dd for for example
for example Dalton was adamant
unequivocal on the issue of gays in the
military
correct and it was just about the first
issue he took on raise this again no I'm
just can ask to you an innocent question
he was absolutely unequivocal on this
and then suddenly he was very equivocal
on it well I mean I can give you my view
of what happened which was that the
president wanted to lift the ban on gays
in the military the Republican in
Congress made it clear that they would
attach legislation to a bill that the
president wanted to sign like family
medical leave legislating the ban in to
loss of the president had essentially
two options he could sign an executive
order that would have been overturned by
congressional action or he could
negotiate and he chose to negotiate
because he believed that would make a
difference in the lives of men and women
in uniform it didn't work out as well as
he would have liked but his intentions
were did he know going in that well he
didn't know that the signals coming back
from the hill would be that we're gonna
attach legislation to something you
really want
would be intense opposition to this uh I
don't think he promised he'd I don't
know how much time you spend thinking
about it it wasn't in the top fifty
fifty-one it was the opposite the first
thing he did no but not yes he didn't
start it it came out it was asked about
it by the New York Times it appeared on
page one of the New York Times and it
thrust it to the forefront of his agenda
during the very closing days of the
transition that was not a strategic move
on the president's part the president
want to start with the economy he always
wanted to start with the economy events
transpired and people can think whatever
they want about how that turned out but
he negotiated because he thought he
could make it better
but it didn't work who lies more
Republicans are Democrats what about the
gays are think Lincoln is good you know
log cabin Republican do you find that
only an amazing thing Republicans lie
more DD i-- boo though Tony a Democrat
say there's no different it to draw the
entire Democratic parties a lot okay
explain yourself no well let's see
Roosevelt said we're not gonna be
sending your boys off to any Foreign
Wars
oh right and after Pearl Harbor he
should have abided by that that would
have been smarter to go you know what I
don't want to go back on my word the
Martians have landed but I'm not gonna
send your boys oh but we now know that
he knew but you knows what gives your
type of bad reputation we now know of
course
we now know of course that he knew about
the attack on Pearl Harbor before it
came but that's a I think it'd be good
for sixty minutes perhaps look into that
yeah a 20-story Pearl Harbor
cutting-edge stuff has has political
correctness of seriously damaged
political satire sort of a humorous well
I mean I'm not sure there was that much
damage but sure I think that since we're
a nation of immigrants and ethnic humor
is the base of much of our humor in the
country and almost all that the humorous
now politically incorrect it's certainly
withdrawn a large catalog of of jokes
that politicians would normally use the
only the only ethic Yuma you can use now
is on your own ethnicity and even then I
think you can probably get into trouble
so I think certainly political
correctness has reduced it but I think
from a fairly low base are you a [ __ ]
yeah what for you know it you know I
think the only difference is now that we
we we now have a trillion more comedy
about political correctness right I mean
I don't think there's really that big a
difference and we're better often I mean
it has gone a little too far in some
respects but I think we're better off in
many respects we hollow we better off
because I think people are more
sensitive about the language that they
use in ways that I mean you can go too
far in some respects we have become so
we have to be careful about what we
laugh at yes matter hasn't had a kind of
stifling almost dare I say crippling
things you mean challenge don't you
don't
none of these even the builder al has
made a racist joke in this panel and I
think they've been pretty funny so I
guess there's plenty of of stuff no I
don't think that has to do with race
yeah but a little manual correctness
excuse me I think I have some waited
just title to say what political
incorrectness is it's not about
ethnicity necessarily to me it's always
just been about telling it truthfully
the reason I'm against political
correctness is because it gives liberals
a bad name everybody rolls can't afford
a bad name
everybody is trying to be politically
correct pat buchanan says there's no
room in my campaign for racists or
anti-semites of course not those
positions were filled months ago
I'm gonna write some of these down Tony
hi I'm at Rascals tomorrow night and I'm
gonna use some of these at the comedy
cave in Cleveland but but often when
politicians try to be funny
they aren't or they're offensive in some
advertent or inadvertent way and the
next thing you know they've given some
mealy-mouthed apology for what they said
the night before correct correct
al demonically correct al d'amato
what went on Imus and did a you know
those but a kind of a buck-toothed coke
bottle impression of judge Ito who is
does not speak in any way with the
Japanese an American and who it turns
out thanks to 60 minutes was a jerk we
found that out last night but you know
or the math you know okay well anyway so
D'Amato last night D'Amato goes on and
our D'Amato is criticized and he says
I'm sorry if anyone was offended and
then he's criticized for not saying I'm
sorry I did this and then remember he
got like a heart almost like a heart
attack it wasn't right in the hospital
because the strat his friend says he's
under a lot of stress I thought that was
pretty funny
but when when when was a desk he's gonna
do his impression I want to hear his
impression of a Japanese guy having a
heart attack that's nicely politically
incorrect varial it isn't everybody
didn't offend anybody did I know well
defended everybody fair but what was it
dick armey who referred to Barney Frank
as Barney [ __ ] yes a slip of the tongue
morally and he said it was just often I
say that word Frank it comes out there
to you so you have a dick [ __ ] our dick
armey is a [ __ ] or a big bag but that's
if they had a couple of our or just a
dick Armey's a big dick this comes out
it's just like we're like you know I
like dick armey that comes out but you
are those things planned do they know
they're going to get into hot water but
they make me point in me specifically on
that he stumbled over his words a lot
and everybody who knows big army knows
what wine they get there's a
why in the world is one more big pile
there
the same politicians don't lie and why
would he use that phrase when he anybody
would know that would get him in trouble
the fact is he stumbled over his time
maybe he didn't know of course he was
he's actually a fairly smart fella he
drinks a little hold on tonio that I was
reading at that dinner but he has a
constituency out there who who loved it
right no I don't think so I could use I
mean I think that's a caricature of
conservatism to think that there that
there are this constituency who likes
hearing that sort of thing and it's a
conceit of some people to think that
that's that way so I know I happen to
think that it was a trip step of his
tongue you see and that he didn't intend
it and he was feeling very bad about the
fact that he came out that way al al and
that's yeah and this alone he doesn't
have a heart attack so from a
professional point of view from a
working comedian point of view who do
you want to see mr. Nick's book now Dick
Armey because I would love to hear more
I mean you know this is worse than oj
saying the disguise was to go to Knott's
Berry Farm you know it's on that same
level pat buchanan you know was roj this
year are you know i as long as he's in
it that's good father no but once it
it's i think we can fairly say it's
gonna be clinton and dull from a working
point of view not as a citizen as a
comedian dolls better you want you want
though
brain did i love him but he's brain dead
hmm dull I mean you want as a comedian
you want dull but as a comedian who's in
the pocket of the Democrats I want clef
okay let me let me get carcinoma and we
can take some questions from the
audience for 10 or 15 minutes Jennifer
I'm sorry
who what's the question uh is Ross Perot
good fodder well he sort of done father
isn't he
no no well I'm getting warmed up he's
gonna do it again evidently Dana Carvey
did hilarious Ross Perot and saved our
1992 season yes Erin so god bless Ross
Perot
uh Hillary um well I really like Hillary
so this is
it's probably probably a good example of
why a comedian shouldn't get to know
people in public life because she is
very different in person from the
caricature of her and she's she's act
part of the reason I really like hers
that she laughs a lot and most comedians
like anyone who laughs at their jokes
yeah Clinton well tell me why one of the
jokes that she laughs at though oh she
loves white water jokes just nothing you
know one laughs harder than Hillary had
a good good susan thomases joke he's
right that when you meet them very often
the reason one of the reasons I got to
the top is because they are so good at
meeting people Clinton when I met him at
that dinner yes he won me over so fast
not that I was against him but you know
it remind me of the time I met Don King
I met I swear to God I met Don King for
10 seconds coming off an award show when
he was coming on and I always thought
Don King the lowest form of scum on the
earth tenth bill by a fantastic young
man you could be one if you want to get
a medal for what you do bill fantastic
as a Don Kings are great
what a great and that same thing with
gluten so here is easily seduced as the
press absolutely yeah that Gingrich and
and I didn't like him but but he didn't
like me we had a little discussion at
the last Correspondents Dinner last year
no we just we just started talking about
I I know you're not supposed to talk
about politics of these things I said to
him but I couldn't help it I was talking
to Speaker of the House so I said you
know I'm worried about that by sending
everything back to the states the states
are going to have to compete with each
other and drive benefits down for the
poor and he said what's wrong with that
and we but the subtext of our
conversation was I don't like you
yeah I don't like you yeah so so I don't
like everyone I meet but I how becomes a
he thought you were Bob Frank I was I
was very impressed when I met Clint I
met him at President Nixon's funeral I
really liked him and he tried to pick up
my wife
you know you're doing so well Thank You
mr. Rajesh my money I have a question
over here mr. Schaefer safer over here
over my question would be - Allen - bill
I guess the question is isn't most
comedy based in the truth truisms
whether somebody says something or
physically does something or has a
situation that they become involved in
is that always the the comedian's
defenses while they set it and let the
public make the decision you touched on
that a little bit earlier about the
truth well that's what Bill was saying
that comedians are the truth tell us I
think I said that before missus is that
always the defense though that hey they
said it so therefore I can say whatever
I want
Oh what why do you need why do you need
a defense if you're a comedian well like
take I'm well let's go down I miss at
the dinner I mean it was like he made
the truth that you know Clinton did say
the line about Oh baby
and then everybody took that as being
offensive and then it went you know that
would be that it is about you know a
baseball player
in a second what kind of that's the
truth yeah that's just not a great joke
yeah right so you you would agree that
that was inappropriate or now a good
joke points up a truth that you can't
get to an end the other way but humor
let me put another way we're truth
tellers
Thank You Gotti what are they ever it's
what I can answer that I think for
everyone almost everyone a pure
undiluted Hemnes no it was in my country
and Tony can vouch for that but I'm
happy to do and it's been fun but it's
now time to go someone in public life
and liking them makes your job more
difficult does meeting someone and
disliking them as much as you thought
you would make it easier yes there's
quite a quite a bit in my book about the
speaker and our meeting fortunately made
oh I'm sorry
Family Values and was this in relation
to the speaker plays Joe and Jackie
Gingrich
Thank You Al Franken if you were
traveling in Egypt and you were writing
a postcard - charlton heston what is it
that you would say
um Oh divide this see for me knots
that's not right political ones here for
this is a question to the comedian so
I'll let you identify yourselves is
there a conspiracy of silence regarding
Lyndon LaRouche in this particular
campaign or will you give him his fair
share
yeah it's a conspiracy man I'd look into
it
and then LaRouche once called Walter
Mondale the most evil man between a
senator let me repeat them who is the
funniest person in the house or the
Senate Anderson Sonny Bono is very funny
I mean he actually is who would have
thought right that a guy you yeah Cher's
big nose jokes for five years um who
else's doll is funny ice army I hear
dogs do this oh man not again god
guess our Baines alone John just follow
me
Clark Clifford was very funny Clark
Clifford and tell a whole and thank God
he's behind bars again what a menace to
society if he was on the loose
what about foreign pose could you be
more vague please question
personalities aside are there any funny
issues what's wrong with these people
Washington's ah funny issues yeah
AIDS always rape rape genocide and how
it always a crowd-pleaser
ever since Vietnam and Watergate it's
harder to be a truth teller yeah I was
wondering if Chelsea Clinton is really
off-limits I think that since her hair's
grown and she's looking a lot better
than another couple of years she won't
be
she is becoming a very very pretty young
man she really is to see that growth
it's really great she's self-assured
pandering to the administration again
what's that know she's looks interesting
for everyone on the panel straight
answer if it's possible what has been
the biggest surprise so far in campaign
96 Dede
I'd have to say if if anybody had asked
a year ago how the Republican primary
would turn out and where we would be at
this point everybody in this room would
have picked Bob Dole I don't think
there's been a lot of support you don't
subscribe Roger I know work for Arlen
Specter and that's a surprise that he
didn't do better
he's guessing my luck I actually I I had
two scenarios for a Specter victory one
was a plane crash the second one he
takes Anita Hill as his running mate
well no but Chloe was a bus crash but it
played out stole was the whole everyone
gretchy on Gingrich what's it's like
though Siri working for a candidate who
you know does not have a chance well
there there are Clause candidates who
run to make a point
Eugene McCarthy against the war in
Vietnam Arlen Specter on the issue of
choice who run for some more noble
purpose than just winning the office and
actually those kind of campaigns are fun
because you're you're not gambling the
White House you're just out there trying
to make an ideological point you're
playing with the house money well
they're all playing with the house money
correct half who did better McCarthy or
Specter well neither one of it got to be
President
I got the same answer I gave before let
me ask let me change this question
slightly do press secretaries ever lie
alright would be it would be dishonest
if I said in my entire life I never told
a lie I know as press actor
I don't didn't mean dead today no I
think you believes me so it doesn't
matter what I say you trade on your
credibility as a press secretary it's
the only thing you have to do what you
trade on your credibility if but
sometimes don't you lie for the good of
the country
it's never inure interesting boss's
interest to lie it it's just I mean
during the Cuban Missile Crisis they
lied to the people sometimes because it
wasn't the best interest of the come in
there I guess there are instances I
didn't have one of those you you go out
there and say things that are wrong
which is mortal Roger like because you
have bad information it's trying to
clean up after yourself and that's very
uncomfortable I mean they tell you the
lie so you don't think that you're lying
that has been known to happen right to
some people sitting well what was it
that Ron Ziegler said that we're not
bombing Cambodia everything I said
yesterday this point about Watergate
isn't everything I said Larry speaks got
sent out to say like you know ten hours
before the invasion of Grenada there are
no plans to invade Grenadiers the US
forces were heading toward Grenada right
well that's exacting art dolars it is
but he didn't lie because he didn't know
the truth
what is this does a good press secretary
not want to know the truth oh just like
a ghost no worth it you would come on no
you don't want to I mean sometimes I
suppose inform in issues of national
security do you have to make that
compromise and that's a very there are
so few cases where that is actually true
where you're going to compromise
national security if you do not know the
truth that it's it's a very tiny
universe but it is one that exists and I
think you know in order to protect
national security if you different
people have different Earp rotational
thinks is in
nation's security interest is not
necessarily with the press things but
those are very very rare judgments
there's a whole much broader scope where
the press secretary always wants to know
the truth is the press secretary lied
too often by his master I think no it's
more likely to be staffers who are
trying to spin you you have to actually
figure out which staffers to believe and
have an antenna for when you're being
spun and we really play the job of a
reporter inside our organization to try
to find out what the facts are so we
don't go out and what the operative
truth of the moment is yes because
staffers try to resolve there or to
further their own agendas what they
believe is the right thing to do through
this sometimes the mouthpiece of the
press secretary it happens all the time
one more question
this is a question from the celebrated
dick tuck with the impeachment of
Richard Nixon an issue of national
security a case can be made yeah
can I you do better than that day yeah
well anyway morally I'm you know I'm I
got your wire and I showed up I am you
know I should have very disappointed I
should have been a little suspicious
when I the ticket it was you know Sununu
few frequent flyer miles but anyway I'm
here and I'm just but I'm glad that you
suggested it's all over I recall in 1972
60 minutes did a show called can anybody
here stop muskie and the answer was no I
don't live here so I come in the Wild
West and I'm telling you it ain't over
by cept if you think that this for the
next five months we're going to have
what's muskie call this year well we're
going to have Dole and Quentin and
nothing else you're going to get a big
present surprise there is going to be
lots happening out there that is going
to say shocked Washington but it won't
shock the rest of the country somebody
finally did stop muskie oh yes quite a
few people did yeah
ain't funny so it is this primary but it
will get funny that's the beauty of as I
see you guys will love what's going to
happen I you know there's an openness
did you love Richard whitey
clamp and on that one are we let's do
one more question do I become yes sorry
hold on zoom
what about speaker Gingrich is
fascination with zoo animals if you
might have reporters and on that note
well that's why I'm so upset about not
getting into the front Air Force One
because they have a little zoo there
they have a komodo dragon donated to the
zoo and then you couldn't get to see
that peanuts up there to I think we have
to wrap at this point thank you very
much for joining us ladies and gentlemen
our reception continues in the adjacent
room so please feel free to stick around
and meet our panelists early
one facility
okay
is a perfect